[Aplausos]
[Música]
está bien padre en silencio no
disfrutarlo a veces es complicado
se han puesto a pensar en esa idea
de que todos tenemos una ardilla en
nuestra cabeza y de repente me pregunto
por qué tiene que ser es animal porque
en una mariposa o porque nunca más león
o un gato digo tal vez no que habría en
esta cavidad
pero siempre tiene que ser algo
diferente
eso a mí me cambio en muchos aspectos
empezando por mi nombre
siempre era como bien complicado de que
así te llamas
o eres familiar de alguien
o no sé es como qué
es muy familiar se presta a cuestiones
de confusión normalmente la gente piensa
que soy ese primo del amigo
porque tengo muchos familiares pero
realmente son poquitos si voy conociendo
nuevas personas y creo que eso me nutre
como les comentaba me dedico a hacer
diseño a veces género imágenes
las cuales me gusta que vayan a la
cabeza de otra persona
creo que todos ubicamos el logotipo de
estas letras rojas que están aquí atrás
obviamente tuve que crear el significado
de esta padre porque google nos hace
seres inteligentes
pero también está padre cuando
encontramos estas cosas que están
escondidas si todos ven el logotipo
pues es como una tipografía muy normal
es una tipografía que diseñó un
arquitecto italiano
y que no sé si él intentó meter este
mensaje oculto dentro de las letras está
bien padre porque cuando mencionó oculto
siento que captó toda su atención
nos encantan las cosas que no podemos
ver pero ahí están si nos fijamos
tenemos una especie de clavija
con héctor adentro del logotipo en la
letra e y en la letra d
pero también nos genera una happy face
cómo podemos resumir esto conectar
nuevas ideas
nos hace más felices
y creo que por eso estamos el día de hoy
escuchando a tantas personas con ideas
frescas con ideas que nos motiven
en méxico somos especiales especialistas
en la palabra esperanza
sí y les traje como una pequeña muestra
de lo que vamos a sacar al mercado
donde dijimos bueno en méxico somos
especialistas en la esperanza y por qué
no grande arla crearle una marca un
empaque y decirte aquí tienes 300 gramos
de esperanza la puedes usar como tú
quieras
es de uso personal
y muchas veces medicinal y obviamente
recreativo
qué les parece si estamos en este tema
como encaminados a la parte creativa
hacemos un parecéis hacemos un pequeño
ejercicio de interpretación mental va a
estar súper súper fácil
cuando yo les diga una palabra
ustedes van a pensar en una imagen la
más fácil la primera que se les venga a
la mente no es una competencia
simplemente es que me ayuden a es claro
a esclarecer este punto
qué sucede si les digo la palabra
amarillo
piensan en un color el cual es el más
radiante
que muchas veces nos refiere a la
felicidad
y sabemos que es amarillo porque no es
rojo no es verde no es morado es
amarillo aquí y en china es global si el
significado que nos genera nuestra mente
es global
ahora qué sucede si les digo la palabra
perro
tal vez algunos imaginen un animal
o tras una bola de pelos compartidas tal
vez otros que sean mucho más
descriptivos imaginan a ese perrito con
la lengua de fuera
qué les parece si vamos más allá y les
digo la palabra
amor
algunos van a pensar en un corazón otros
en su familia otros en sus hijos
algunos van a pensar en una fotografía
que tiene la forma de corazón y adentro
está la foto de sus hijos más o menos
estaba ya jugando con su mente porque ya
lo logré
si se fijan cada palabra tiene una
cierta connotación
y es muy diferente en cada cerebro de
cada persona cada una le va dando el
significado y lo va acomodando en su
cerebro
qué piensan si les digo la palabra
carpiano
si la repetimos tres veces el mensaje
llega mucho más directo y se les va a
grabar tal vez es una palabra que no
tienen en su vocabulario o que no está
en su mente que es una enfermedad que
normalmente les dan los diseñadores por
estar todo el día en la compu
obviamente pensaron en un carro y
pensaron en un piano
el entendimiento es diferente y se va
haciendo cada vez más difícil hay
palabras que nos generan emociones como
la palabra kobe
siento que es una palabra que genera
miedo que tiene un color negro
y que es muy difícil de asimilar es la
peor palabra y ahorita podemos decirle a
alguien
genera una emoción
si nos vamos al lado contrario qué
sucede con la palabra juan gabriel
dejó de ser un nombre para convertirse
en un icono de música
sentimiento y cultura ya no es su nombre
cada persona le da una connotación
diferente
creo que las personas
somos seres ultra visuales
gracias a la magia de instagram
levanten la mano quien no tiene
instagram
gracias a instagram nos volvemos
fotógrafos al instante queremos capturar
momentos para ganarle al futuro
pero aquí es donde me pregunto qué
sucede con las personas que tienen una
enfermedad mental
como sale su fotografía qué sucede con
las personas
que tienen bipolaridad o que tienen
esquizofrenia o que tienen demencia es
bien complicado descifrar esa foto
yo no sé si tengo estas tres
enfermedades de seguro tengo una de
ellas
y cuando salgamos del cobat vamos a
tener más
desgraciadamente
si ya estamos en este tema que no es
nada grato que son las enfermedades
les quiero contar una historia pero no
sé si tengan tiempo
si tiene
super
necesito que me ayuden a contar ese
tiempo con su respiración
vamos a tomar aire vamos a hacer que
nuestros pulmones y que obviamente
oxigena nuestro cerebro sí
lo vamos a tomar y lo vamos a dejar ahí
5 segundos
perdón 5
listos
ok
empezamos 1 2 3
prueba rápida del cobi
pero que todos estamos sanos pero que
todos tenemos esta fuerza para seguir
yo tuve que aprender a respirar
tuve que ir a terapia
[Música]
para darme cuenta
que mi molde que mi envase estaba mal
esto que les cuento es super personal
nada más lo sabe mi esposa
como 200 alumnos a los cuales les di
clases y que siempre les hablaba este
tema
porque me gustaba más hablarle de cosas
de experiencias que de diseño de
logotipos de marcas de negocios siento
que los diseñadores
estamos hechos de experiencias
tal vez no todos alcancen a ver
pero mi postura si se fija trato de no
bailar
mi postura cambió hace 15 años yo estaba
de esta forma iba por la vida con los
pies así era bien complicado tomar
decisiones
iba con las piernas arqueadas
mi madre la cual me dio el mejor regla
el regalo que ahorita más atesoro
realmente en la vida
pero también me llegó esta terapia hace
15 años
fue psicológica pero también fue un
poquito chamánica
y me gustó bastante porque te arregla el
interior a través del exterior
creo que nuestro cuerpo es un reflejo de
lo que llevamos día a día se nos va
acumulando así como las emociones que es
lo que hizo esta psicóloga
me estoy arreglando el molde el envase
me empezó a decir
no respiras bien
tu postura está mal y me empezó a
arreglar me dejó ciertos ejercicios los
cuales me ayudaron a tener una postura
mucho más firme ante la vida
y arreglo los pies
igual voy a girar para que se entienda
un poquito más yo antes iba por la vida
así
arqueado
cualquier cosa que pueda tirar
de los ejercicios
ahora voy un poquitito
flexionado
obviamente no voy a caminar así como
no sé cómo changuito
pero me arreglo la postura me hizo que
en ciertas ocasiones
pueda descansar mis mis pies y mis
piernas
platicando con esta chamánica diagonal
psicóloga diagonal ave del viento y todo
lo que ustedes quieran
le pregunté
cómo puedo tener más energía
y obviamente todos los chamanes quieren
guardarse sus secretos y me dice eso no
te lo puedo revelar
y yo ya mi mamá ya pago
hace crear le dije ok está bien
obviamente en la siguiente sesión me lo
dijo
y qué es lo que yo hacía me paraba en el
centro de un lugar y me dice tienes que
visualizar
como de tus pies nacen raíces y se van
hacia el centro de la tierra
y ahí es donde está la verdadera energía
no está en el cielo
[Música]
o tal vez sí
y eso lo sigo haciendo me sigue dando
energía o al menos mi mente lo asimila
de esa manera
ya para cerrar esta plática
qué les parece si les dejo con una
reflexión
la reflexión de mis piernas no se crean
gracias a esto descubrí que no soy tan
especial
siento que el creativo se le percibe
como un [ __ ] raro o como una [ __ ] está
y cuidado donde se metan con su punto
tengo la teoría de que todos somos
creativos en potencia
el hecho radica en saber qué hacemos con
el exterior
para que nos afecte nos cambien nos
motive el interior
ahora si los voy a dejar con una
interpretación
no voy a cantar
pero dice así
me gustaría que siguieran imaginando
quiero estar en seguida y con ustedes
imaginen que lleguen a su casa
su perro corre a recibirlos se emociona
se alegra de verlos le chupa la cara
pero no es porque los ame
es porque dentro de ustedes tienen
huesos y se los quiere comer
pero no lo hará
porque los ama de forma incondicional
aunque sean ustedes un vil costal de
huesos andante
busquemos siempre la belleza de llegar
al interior de las cosas
gracias
[Aplausos]